NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
GIF-O-MERICAL.
THE BEST PART OF INFOMERCIAL IS
WHEN IT GOES ALL BLACK AND WHITE
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN EVERYBODY IS
LIKE "OH, NO!
I CAN'T CARRY ALL MY
SKI EQUIPMENT.
SOMEBODY TEACH ME HOW TO BE
A HUMAN BEING AND USE MY
LIMBS PROPERLY AGAIN.
IF ONLY THERE WAS AN EASIER
WAY."
WELL, THANKFULLY THESE
GLORIOUS MOMENTS ARE VERY
WELL-DOCUMENTED IN GIF FORM,
SO I WILL SHOW YOU A GIF
INFOMERCIAL FROM THE SUB
REDDIT WHERE DID THE SODA
GO.
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT TO YOU
GIVE ME THE VOICEOVER LINE THAT
SHOULD GO DID WITH IT.
FIRST ONE, FIRST ONE, THIS
ONE.
FUH, FUH, FUH. OH! OH, OH, NO,
FU! NO!
DOWN THE HOOD OF THE CAR.
YOU KNOW THAT WHOLE, THAT
GUY'S WHOLE LIFE IS JUST
THAT.
OVER AND OVER.
REGGIE WATTS.
ARE YOU TIRED OF TRYING
TO CONTROL WATER IN ALL OF
ITS VARIOUS FORMS?
>> Chris: RORY SCOVEL.
>> HAVEN'T FOUND TIME FOR
YOURSELF SINCE SHEILA DIED?
>> Chris: NEXT ONE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE ALL [BLEEP]
CHIMPS. LIKE, THERE'S NO
OTHER-- RORY.
>> HAVING TROUBLE COOKING
EVER SINCE SHIELA DIED?
>> Chris: POINTS.
REGGIE.
>> ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED BY
YOUR FOOD'S INABLE TO
LEVITATE?
>> Chris: WELL, NOW THERE'S THE
HOVER FISH.
LAST ONE, LAST ONE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> Chris: KATE.
>> IS YOUR INSISTENCE ON
OWNING A TRAY KEEPING YOU ALONE.